documents read that's slow
[Music]
I was a trainer at a gym and the first
time they gave me was this angelic woman
he met you and Florida and you're my
server at a restaurant as soon as I laid
eyes on you I felt with you
we met on OkCupid I'll be honest when we
first met I didn't know that I would
ever see you as anything more than a
friend I think it was tough in the
beginning because I was still in party
mode and I thought you were just gonna
come along with me and we're gonna go
out every night our second date you have
a booty jean shorts on with your ass
hanging out I was just so uncomfortable
and right then I was like no this might
be way more than I could handle in a
relationship how did you feel when I
came out to you as transgender at first
I was shocked
because I had a very weird conception of
people who women who are trans I was
doing a stunt and hurt my back doing it
i slick slipped a disc and kind of put
it off didn't really pay much attention
to it end up landing basically in the
hospital and had that surgery character
for taking you to emergency room and
then finding out that like the surgery
that you had wasn't what they were
expecting because it was so much worse
and I remember getting in my car like I
don't even think I got ready and driving
there and getting there and getting to
the room and it was an empty bed I was
feeling like what if you didn't wake up
so then we fought about on the way home
I was like what the [ __ ] wrong with
you like why can't you just have a good
time who cares about my but I felt like
kind of almost rejected and like I
couldn't be my authentic self entire
process of coming out to you I've never
done that before I leave someone's face
in that point forward you weren't
holding my hand you weren't telling me
how beautiful I was anymore you weren't
being super sweet so you were basically
making me feel really uncomfortable
because he kept looking at me funny to
be able to see someone at their lowest
low helped build a relationship we are
meant to be together because all this
stuff we've been through there's they
can bend we just really worked on our
communication and I think that's how we
got through it I answered all your
questions that you know of course you
had questions that I was filling one
than ready to answer that point was
whatever because our connection was
stronger than and that it's hard to live
somewhere where you don't have family
and I feel like in these past two years
you've become my family yeah obviously
we've had our ups and downs but among
men ease disbelief we have held strong I
wouldn't change a thing
yes I just wanna thank you for
everything that you have done for me and
for accepting every part of me I
couldn't have done all this without you
[Music]